à genoux tous les deux
comment tu vas en cloud jacques je
reconnais plus le vieux chalet la nature
ça va faire du bien
cela car un vrai pouvoir de guérison
merci les tenues d'accord sally hay
rêve qui me font téléphone est éteint
quand on se voit tu connais le protocole
c'est pas comme ça qu'on ponctionne été
complètement débile
[Musique]
hé
il y avait un attrait nettoie moi ce
merdier et surtout ne m'oblige pas à me
déplacer
s'il vous plaît je ferai tout ce que
vous voulez je vous promets que je te
dis que tu fous rires
en danger à genoux tous les deux pics
des jeux voir vos mains moi aussi je
suis flic que s'est il passé c'est elle
qui s'est jeté sur moi elle morte il y
fit tuer quelqu'un si ce gars là est
bien flic il tirera pas se rendre ses
collègues va me chercher mon pistolet
[Musique]
on a un problème abrège ses souffrances
ont pu fêter ensuite oncle à cette
affaire compris
je sais qu'il a alors il est où ton
copain
janin il nous faut des preuves c'est
notre seule dans mon appareil photo avec
ça vous aurez tout ce qu'il vous faut
c'est pas le moment de vous dégonfler
d'accord d'accord
arrêtez moi simplement la fille est
votre nièce ne courra aucun danger
si vous touchez un cheveu de manif
[Musique]
cambrai la porte
pour qu on serre les coudes
c'est plus complexe quand sa réplique la
famille proche d'andré jack
je connais les hommes comme pour vous
vous servez les autres pour arriver à
vos fins
six mois l'emmerdeuse ce qui va faire
plonger
[Musique]